news now breaking news alert
an nhp trooper flown to umc after trying
to stop a suspected carjacker on the
i-15 right now the i-15 near sahara shut
down in both directions a
very dangerous and dramatic situation
unfolded just a few hours ago good
afternoon and thank you for joining us
i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casadas we have live
team coverage for you from the scene to
the hospital
and on the traffic impact but we start
tonight with victoria saha live near the
15
and sahara victoria
this is still a very active scene here
right behind me you can see dozens of
police cars still
lined up both sides of the freeway still
closed on i-15
we know that the trooper is injured and
the suspect did not survive after a
20-minute chase
within the past hour we've received new
information from the nevada association
of public safety officers
they tell us the chase started around 12
30 this afternoon and
involved parole and probation trying to
stop a woman
troopers jumped in to help and as one
was laying down spike strips
we're told the female suspect hit him
with her car sending him through the
windshield
multiple authorities stopped that
suspect and believed she was going for
the downed
trooper's weapon they opened fire she
didn't survive
a short time later chopper landed on the
interstate presumably to take that
trooper to umc
people nearby tell me they couldn't
believe what they were hearing
i'm glad no bullets flew over here and
hit me you know what i mean because
the police they were just shooting on
like 20 or 30 times
keys tells us he has had his business
here for a couple of years and he has
never seen
anything like this happen it's been
about four hours since the highway
closed down again a still very active
scene you can see
yellow crime tape still over there in
parts of the intersection reporting live
from i-15 near the sahara avenue exit
victoria saha 8 news now
thank you victoria as she mentioned the
whole situation has shut down the i-15
near sahara both directions
orco mana joins us live with a closer
look at the traffic impact at this hour
orco
well kirsten it's really been a mess on
the interstate all afternoon the i-15
has been backed up for hours
causing major traffic headaches we are
along the i-15
near russell road and you can see that
cars are
barely moving going bumper to bumper and
this is what we've seen
up and down a large portion of the i-15
all day again this is all unfolding
after police say an
hp trooper was injured in a car chase
further north we're being told both
northbound
and southbound lanes of i-15 are still
closed at sahara
metro police also say the i-15 is
currently closed in both directions
between flamingo road and charleston
boulevard additional alerts from the rtc
indicate that access to southbound i-15
is also shut off
from craig road to spring mountain road
and there's no access to i-15 northbound
from blue diamond so again a lot of
traffic out here so try to avoid the
interstate
if you can right now it's still unclear
how long the closures will last
but an attorney with a local public
safety officer's union tells us
the i-15 is expected to be closed and
backed up for at least a few more hours
until about five o'clock
maybe even later so stay with us us for
updates
but right now let's go out to joe moller
who is live at umc
where that trooper was transported a
little bit earlier this afternoon
joe orca we just got an
update an emotional update from a
trooper here outside of umc where
this trooper was transported he said
that the trooper involved that was hit
on the freeway there is now
in critical condition fighting for his
life his family is here
with him at the hospital and so are
dozens of troopers i'll give you a live
look outside of
umc here at this hour throughout the day
we've been watching troopers come
come here and stop and outside the front
door there there are just about a dozen
people waiting for some sort of update
as far as his condition but again he is
fighting for his life now trooper
uh smacker who we just got an update
from just about 10 minutes ago says they
are like one big family
and he says they're all waiting for an
update as well
you know he's a member of our family uh
i've actually i i've worked up with them
several years when together on when we
were both both
working on the overnight shift
and it's it's hard to really concentrate
on anything else you're just here that's
hoping
you're just giving trying to hope that
he recovers
now you're back out here live we're
taking another look outside of umc here
at this hour again we've been watching
troopers
come and go throughout the throughout
the day we watched the family member who
is here by his side uh come a little bit
earlier around 1 45
so there are several units still outside
we know they're all still waiting for an
update just like we are and as soon as
we do learn more about his condition
we'll be sure to pass it along but as
far as the freeways where orco is
uh they expect that to be closed for
several more hours in that update that
they give us but we'll have much
on what was said on our on our social
media pages also at five
and six o'clock here on eight news now
i'll send it back to you in studio
thank you joe well all of our reporters
will remain out there to bring you the
very latest on this story and you can
get all the latest information on our
website 8newsnow.com
at any time